die meiste zeit laufen wir ja einfach
nur auf dem boden herum und haben gar
nicht so eine verbindung dazu oder so
ein verständnis dafür was da unten
eigentlich alles vor sich geht und warum
der boden so unglaublich wichtig und
schützenswert ist und wenn du deinen
garten nicht umgesetzt dann tut das dem
boden richtig richtig gut gehen können
wir also hier stehen lassen dürfen
schnappen wir uns mal die beiden rächen
und los geht's man kann nämlich auch
super gut ohne umgraben gärtnern und
zwar auf allen bodenarten wir haben
schon vier verschiedene gärten gehabt
aus ganz unterschiedlichen böden von
supersonic wie hier jetzt in unserem
küchengarten ist richtig richtig schwer
in unserem allerersten garten und da
haben wir jeweils ohne umgraben super
super erfolge erzielt und damit super
gute erfahrungen gemacht und wie das
ganze funktioniert und warum das so
sinnvoll ist darum soll es heute gehen
die natürliche schichtungen die einen
boden hat gibt ihm nämlich wahnsinnig
viel stabilität dem verhilft ihm dazu
besser wasser speichern zu können
die schützt ihn davor dass durch wind
oder wasser boden abgetragen wird und
deswegen es ist sehr sinnvoll wenn man
die nicht ändert weil wenn man
umgeschichtet man ja die unteren
bodenschichten nach oben und die oberen
nach unten und stört damit zum beispiel
auch die bodentiere ich ihn also erstmal
wird das gefüge zerstört der boden hat
nicht mehr so diese stabilität die ja
eigentlich haben sollte und die ganzen
boden tierchen lieber am gärtnern ja
super super wichtig sind die komme nicht
in schwierigkeiten wenn man um zum
beispiel findet der regenwurm wenn man
die ernte reste eingräbt und die in
tiefere bodenschichten transportiert
beim umgraben seine nahrung nicht mehr
weil er die normalerweise obenauf
liegend auf dem beet sucht und wenn dann
da keine nahrung mehr findet und hat der
echte probleme
es ist auch so wenn wir mal beim
beispiel regenwurm bleiben das ist jetzt
nur eins von ganz vielen wichtigen boden
tieren aber den kann man so gut sehen
und sie sind auch wahnsinnig
faszinierend also bleiben wir mal bei
dem der baut sich jahrgänge jeder
regenwurm hat übrigens auch eingang in
dem er wirklich wohnt also die haben ein
festes zuhause und diese gänge sind
nicht nur für die regenwürmer super
wichtig sondern zb auch für die ganzen
kleinen
mikroorganismen die im boden leben die
ganz oft in den gängen leben die gänge
sind wirklich sehr sehr bevölkert das
wasser kann über die gänge abfließen das
sind also schnellstraßen viel wenn es
mal richtig geregnet die gänge belüften
dem boden und auch pflanzenwurzeln super
gerne durch regen werden länge weil sie
da nicht so doll durch die erde bohren
müssen mit ihren wurzeln das alles macht
man kaputt wenn man den boden umgräbt
und da umgraben absolut nicht sein muss
und er dann ohne umgraben eigentlich
sogar noch viel weniger arbeit macht als
wenn man um grip was ja auch super
anstrengend ist also das kann man sich
wirklich sparen
finde ich super schön wenn immer mehr
leute anfangen ohne umgraben zu gärtnern
und eben auf eine boden schonendere art
und weise ihren garten bewirtschaften
und darum soll es heute gehen also das
ist mir wirklich ein anliegen weil die
boden tierchen sie sind so cool und wir
sollten wirklich alles in unserer macht
stehende versuchen um die zu
unterstützen da gibt es so coole
kandidaten ist auch ganz wichtig dass
man ein aktives bodenleben hat zum
beispiel der mit stickstoff im boden
verfügbar ist es gibt sogar boden
tierchen die stickstoff aus der luft
fixieren können und viele pflanzen
verfügbar machen können und so weiter da
kann ich auch mal noch mal eine
artikelserie oder so zu machen
vielleicht mit meiner mitarbeiterin
decke die ja ihre masterarbeit über das
gärtnern ohne umgraben im prinzip
geschrieben hat und sich mit bodentiefen
richtig gut auskennt oder auch eine
video serie schreibt auf jeden fall
gerne mal in die kommentare wenn ihr
euch für diese kleinen kirchen
interessiert wir freuen uns immer wenn
wir eine lanze für die brechen können
und da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
informationen über das bodenleben
streuen können und wie man den boden am
besten aufbaut aber ich will auch gar
keinen fall irgendwie jetzt hier
angreifen weil er seinen boden umgräbt
überhaupt nicht ich finde es toll wenn
mehr leute versuchen ihren boden boden
schon dazu bearbeiten aber jeder der
rausgeht und gerd hat und ein bisschen
was von seinem essen selber anbauen ist
eine super sache egal ob man mit oder
ohne umgraben gehalten hat vielleicht
kann ich ja ein paar gedankenanstöße da
draußen wirken ja aber wie stellt man
das denn jetzt an dass man ohne umgraben
gärtnern kann also wie funktioniert das
wir machen das so dass wir unsere beete
einfach auf der wiese anlegen und zwar
mit ganz viel komfort
wie kompostieren selber super gerne und
finde es ganz toll wenn man da
kreisläufe im garten schließen kann wenn
man die abfälle kompostiert den mist von
unseren tieren kompostieren wir und
können ihn so wieder im garten aus
bringen um unsere beete super fruchtbar
zu machen
wir kaufen aber auch gerade wenn wir den
garten neu anlegen und man viel kompass
braucht auch ganz gerne grünschnitt
kompost im recyclinghof zu der ist nicht
besonders teuer und das wird sehr stark
kontrolliert also da gibt es ein ral
gütesiegel das sehr gerade in
deutschland sehr sehr streng
kontrolliert wird da könnt ihr also auch
kompost zu kaufen ohne dass sie angst
haben ist dass ihr euch da irgendwie
schadstoffe in den garten reinhold da
bekommt man auch immer eine checkliste
dazu wo die charge untersucht wurde auf
schadstoffe das einzige was manchmal ein
problem ist klassik müll der manchmal in
dem grünschnitt kompost enthalten ist
wenn irgendwann eine plastiktüte mit
kompostiert wurde oder so dann hat man
manchmal setzen drin da werde ich also
darauf achten einen plastik freien oder
möglichst plastik freien kompass zu
kaufen weil das ist nicht schön wenn man
das im garten aus bringt aber ansonsten
kann man da auch wunderbar kommt es zu
kaufen
im ersten jahr danach braucht man dann
auch keinen kompost mehr kaufen das
reicht absolut was man in einem normalen
wir hatten selbst kompostiert weil man
diese schicht leben nur einmal anlegt
und dann bringt man alle zwei bis drei
jahre nochmal zwei bis drei zentimeter
kommt was auf den beeten aus um das ab
und zu mal wieder zu erneuern aber da
ist eben nur einmal diese große aktion
nötig wo man vielleicht kommt es zu
kaufen muss und dann hat man seine ruhe
kann ohne umgraben gärtnern füttert das
bodenleben hat eine super super humus
haltige erde die wasser richtig gut
speichert die regenwürmer anzieht wie so
ein regenwurm magnet also gerade in
unserem ein garten da wimmelt es richtig
von regen willmann und anderen boden
tierchen und kann den richtig richtig
gut tun und ich habe ja auch letztens
schon mal darüber geredet
es ist auch super super arbeit sparen so
zu gärtnern weil wir sehr viel weniger
gießen müssen weil sehr viel wasser in
dem kompost und in den bodenschichten
gespeichert wird und weil wir kaum noch
unkraut haben
dafür ist es natürlich elementar wichtig
dass man unkrautfrei kompostiert das
heißt unkräuter nicht ob den normalen
komposthaufen werfen das ist super super
schwierig so heiß zu kompostieren
als laie wenn das die unkrautsamen und
die unkraut wurzeln abgetötet werden
dafür muss man schon ganz schöner korpus
wird und kompost profi sein um das
richtig hinzukriegen
deswegen haben wir einen unkraut kompost
in der entlegenen ecke im garten wo wir
unsere unkräuter drauf packen und der
normale kompost der prüfung kraut frei
das ist da super wichtig aber wenn du
kompost im recyclinghof kaufst dann
kannst du immer nachfragen wurde der
heiß genug kompostiert dass der
unkrautfrei ist das ist super wichtig
weil dann spart man sich immens viel
arbeit wenn man kaum noch retten muss
darüber habe ich ja auch schon mal ein
video gemacht das kann ich euch gerne
mal da oben verlinkten schaute auf jeden
fall mal rein
das spart enorm viel arbeit im garten
ich habe schon mal ein video gefilmt wo
ich begleitet habe wie wir unsere beete
anlegen also mit diesem kompost wenn du
das noch nicht gesehen hast viele von
euch sind ja schon in meinem kostenlosen
mini kurs dabei einen gemüsegarten boot
camp dann packe ich dir den link noch
mal da oben hin und unten in die video
beschreibung da kommt ihr zum
gemüsegarten boot camp und da zeige ich
ganz genau wie wir diese beete anlegen
ohne umgraben so dass ihr loslegen könnt
und das in ihrem garten auch machen
könnt also ich kann es wirklich
wärmstens empfehlen
wir haben super gute erfahrungen gemacht
und auch ganz ganz viele andere leute
die das schon ausprobiert haben auch das
einzige wo ich wirklich drauf achten
würde ist das wenn ihr kompost verwendet
oder kompost kauft dass der gut
ausgereift ist viele fragen immer ja
kann ich denn in kompost überhaupt gern
weil das heißt ja immer dass der zu
scharf ist und wie ist das der mit
schwarzem und mit mittel zählern
klappt das denn mit denen auch oder
klappt das nicht das klappt wunderbar du
kannst auch schwach zähler sowie
karotten oder zwiebeln karotten ich guck
mal ob ich eine rausziehen kann
sind noch ein bisschen klein aber auch
die kannst du in einem reinen kompost
bethan bauen das ist gar kein thema
solange der kompost richtig reif ist das
heißt der soll schön schwarz und fein
krümelig sein und nach waldboden riechen
ich hoffe man sieht dass jetzt und ganz
fein keine groben stücke mehr enthalten
dann ist es gar kein problem dann
wachsen da auch schwach zähler drin und
kompost enthält sowieso gerade wenn ihr
grünschnitt kompost kauft viel weniger
stickstoff als die meisten leute
annehmen deswegen keine sorge ihr habt
da keine stickstoff überdüngung für eure
schwach sei das funktioniert super gut
mittels ihrer und stark zähler muss man
sogar noch zu düngen auch wenn man so
viel kompost auf den bieten aus bringt
ja und statt dem spaten hast du dann auf
einmal ein anderes ganz wichtiges
gartenwerkzeug das ist der rächen weil
wir damit den kompost verteilen
auflockern wenn wir sehen wollen oder
pflanzen wollen
damit ziehen wir unsere rillen und damit
verteilen wir den mulch auf unseren
beten das heißt eigentlich haben wir
quasi nur ein wichtiges gartenwerkzeug
bei uns ein anderes kommt noch dazu das
ist die doppel grabegabel die verwende
ich super gerne um den boden zu lockern
wenn wir zum beispiel karotten sehen die
ja tief wurzeln wollen und den boden
tief durch trinken wollen dann lockern
wir den boden ohne ihn zu wenden
das ist nämlich boden schonen da wir
wollen ihn ja nicht wenden und dafür
verwenden wir eine doppel grabegabel mit
der man das ganz einfach machen kann und
superschnell super große flächen
bearbeiten kann
ich kann euch mal eine doppel grabegabel
unten in der video beschreibung
verlinken wenn ihr euch eine zulegen
wollte ist ein super tolles werkzeug das
zusammen mit dem rechen eigentlich die
einzigen beiden werkzeuge sind die wir
regelmäßig im garten benutzen dann ist
wo ich natürlich auch noch super
wertvoll wenn man ohne umgraben gärtnert
um den boden weiter zu schützen um
unkräuter zu unterdrücken und wasser im
boden zu halten das bodenleben zu
füttern und so weiter aber darüber habe
ich auf diesem kanal schon so oft
geredet dass ich euch das jetzt erspare
wenn ihr die videos noch nicht gesehen
habt schaut euch auf jeden fall mal auf
dem kanal
da werdet ihr jede menge infos über das
mulchen finden ich habe auch noch mal
ein extra video darüber machen wenn euch
das interessiert und dann sprechen wir
am besten als nächstes darüber wie man
ohne um gold gehört hat oder das hängt
nämlich ganz viel auch mit unserer
technik zusammen dass wir nicht umgraben
also schaue gerne da drüben vorbei dann
erzähle ich dir wie das funktioniert
oder da unten da ist auch noch ein video
dass dich interessieren könnte ansonsten
bis nächsten samstag